[Music]
general stan mcchrystal
is known for commanding the special
operations forces during the obama years
and this is when the special operations
forces were working at maximum capacity
in iraq and afghanistan
it created all kinds of new problems of
communication and bureaucracy
and one of the many things he's known
for is actually helping figure out an
entirely new way
in which large sprawling organizations
can keep everyone
in the loop but that's not what i wanted
to talk to stan mcchrystal about
i wanted to talk to him about what it
means to serve
quietly in a world in which we feel the
need to advertise everything we do on
social media stan mcchrystal has led a
career
that very often is behind the scenes
this
is a bit of optimism
[Music]
stan thanks so much for for doing this
for sure now you come from a line of
soldiers
were you pushed to join the army or did
you want to join the army where'd the
inclination come because you had the
choice
i assume to go in one direction or
another for your career
well you're correct my father was a
soldier and my father's father was a
soldier
my four brothers were soldiers my sister
married a soldier
i married the daughter of a soldier her
three brothers are soldiers her sister's
the widow of a soldier that i served
with so
did anybody ever force me no they didn't
have to as you got older
one i wanted to be my dad because he was
my hero but also
it's just of course this notion of
service
how did it show up at home it was really
through my mother my father had been in
the korean war but i wasn't born then
and then when i was 10 the vietnam war
started to go and he's got six kids and
he deploys to vietnam to command an
infantry battalion
and my mother this is not easy
and we weren't living on a military base
there weren't support structures around
and we take them to the airport one day
in our old station wagon
dropped them off and then as we're
driving back i realized what my mother
had to deal with now
and so i watched her kind of quietly
just do what it had to do
and talk to us and she wasn't a believer
in the vietnam war she was very much
against it
but she loved my father and so for that
and then a subsequent tour so
the sense that you just bear
the burden that is your share the idea
that if everybody has to do something
you should do yours
and just do it quietly stoically might
be the right term and my mother embodied
that
i remember because she went through all
of that and then just when my dad
made brigadier general and theoretically
life would be easy she
died at a very young age she just died
suddenly it was always sad to me
that people don't look harder at that
demographic and say what service really
is because sometimes it's not
in uniform even associated with the
military yeah
we live in a world where i think this
idea of service
has either morphed or even i dare i say
be forgotten
there was a time where service was the
norm like chivalry was like
the norm and all of the rules that went
with chivalry and giving someone your
word
actually meant something and the stories
of world war
ii of young men who committed suicide
because they weren't drafted
where this call to service was the thing
and we can discuss the reasons but
we can at least say that for some reason
this idea of the draw to service and the
call to service
seems to have declined in this modern
day is that a
fair assessment i think you're exactly
correct
that sense of responsibility that i have
a number of expectations to live up to
has decreased now in some ways you say
well
everybody's their own person now they
analyze
everything and decide what to do well
the problem is it's hard to run
a society like that it's hard to have
collective defense it's hard to have
collective
care for those who can't care for
themselves it's hard to have
those things which we do better jointly
than we do
individually it's hard to make that work
unless people
feel a responsibility for
their part of the task well it seems
like america has
over-indexed on rugged individualism
it's an important thing it's a good
thing
but there's a balance and there's a
paradox to being human i think
that every single day we're both
individuals but we're also members of
groups
and we have a responsibility to both
which is we have to take care of
ourselves
but we have a responsibility to the
group and it's never going to be in
perfect balance and it's never going to
be even
it's the seesaw that we have to play
with every day but it should be in play
is the point it shouldn't be lopsided to
rugged individualism
and you can see it in the rise of our
industries i think you know there's an
entire section in the bookshop called
self-help and there's no section in the
bookshop called help others
so we're all trying to learn how to take
care of ourselves but where are we
learning to take care of each other
which i think is interesting i think
that's a great point if you
think about that you know if i was to
say
how do you want young americans wanting
to find it just in our country right now
how do you want them
to process that let's see if they're
coming of age coming out of high school
what should be in their mind well it
doesn't have to be this grand
thing it can be as simple as i have a
responsibility to the fellow human being
to the left and to the right of me
and i would sacrifice my interest to
make sure that they feel safe
psychologically or physically i think
that's right that's why i'm so
passionate about civilian national
service for young americans because
i think you can plant a seed through
behavior getting them to do something
for a year
inspiring them yeah exactly they won't
like it every day but
they will come out of it differently and
they'll come out a bit more thoughtful
and to be clear when you're talking
about national service we're not
necessarily talking about military it
could be
teach for america it could be absolutely
anything that is about
serving society it's particularly not
military because reality is
not everybody's right for the military
and we don't need that big a military if
we started to make military big enough
just to give everybody
a place that would be a mistake instead
health care the environment education
there's so much room for people to go in
for a year or two
give and then when they leave they come
out differently
themselves they're the real product yeah
i think we have to have a constellation
of opportunities
some very local some national and
international
young people can go with those and we've
got to have it paid because otherwise
only families that can support their kid
can give the opportunity
and we've got to make it full-time it's
got to be an immersive
experience it can't be two hours every
saturday it's gotta
disrupt your life a bit the other part
is recognizing the value of the
experience because people come out more
disciplined more experienced
and so universities ought to give
preferential admission to people who've
done service
companies need to get preferential
hiring doesn't mean that
you know you go to the front of the line
everywhere but it means you get
credit for that it's like coming out
you're a veteran of sorts
because military and civilian service
ought to be two sides of the same coin
but at the end of the day you're getting
a better human being you're getting a
better employee
i think a lot of young people there's
the sense of impatience
you know like i gotta get my career
going i love the idea of volunteering
for two years or doing something
you know teaching in a school somewhere
in america or volunteering for
healthcare or whatever
but i feel like i'm gonna lose two years
other people will get ahead of me
in this competition if i go do that
david marquet does some interesting work
where
there's this belief to change behavior
first you have to change someone's
thinking
and then they'll change their behavior
and we see this in companies you give
the powerpoint you explain
what we're doing and then you hope
people will come along and his work has
found that no you force a change in
behavior
and then people change their thinking so
mandating national
service people will come along and
realize how great it is he's exactly
right the other conversation we have to
get
is the one where someone wants to run
for office
and so they are bright young and you
know charismatic and ambitious and they
get in front of
a bunch of people and said i want to be
your congressman and someone says okay
how did you serve and they look down at
their shoes and they go well you know i
was in
this school and then there's law school
and i i didn't
and they go why are you running for
office get out of here i think that
would be very powerful
i mean it's true when we see this in our
politicians right which is this is our
complaint about politicians are they
there to serve us are they there to
win the game and serve themselves i mean
where did they come from
yeah it also strikes me there's plenty
of shared struggle right now in the
united states
how come we're not coming together the
way we should be i mean we seem to be
dividing
in the struggle rather than coalescing
in the struggle and do i have a romantic
view of the way it used to be
or is there actually something different
now i have the same view issue
think about it if you had written a
movie about what would unite the world
what you would do is you'd create an
external threat typically martians think
of one of those movies
where aliens come and the world for the
first time in a long time unites and it
fights off the aliens and
everything's good covert 19's like that
it's something
everybody could hate nobody's gonna love
a virus that kills people
and it was a great opportunity to unite
us internally
and externally you can't blame it on
anybody
and yet the opposite has happened what
we've done is we've gone into
smaller entities almost tribally
and we've linked arms and we've done
that and as a consequence we've
done two things one we've been much less
effective than we needed to be
and second we've missed the opportunity
to have a unifying
theme that brings us together and absent
that
it's pretty easy for societies to
fragment
and that's what i think is so dangerous
right now
now it's also an opportunity there's a
lot of people having the conversation we
are right now
and so i'm hoping that because that
conversation is going on that there are
people saying okay what do we have to do
this race is the interesting question of
sort of to use a modern term to put on
it but branding
you look at the quote-unquote threats
that we face and
they've had really bad branding like we
call it you know global warming
well but we had a really bad winter and
i thought you told me it was warming
or we call it climate change but people
confuse the weather and the climate
they're not the same thing
and why didn't we call it climate cancer
that sounds a lot worse to me
we've done a terrible job at
communicating this existential threat
and so we're not coming together as a
people and you know this from military
which is there is a sense of branding
the enemy
to brand the enemy as this disconnected
threat that they're no longer human
they're they're now a threat
and so i wonder if we have a
responsibility leaders have
responsibility to
better communicate the threats that we
have rather than explaining them
yeah but it seems to me that there's
been a failure of communication from our
leaders
to help us understand the importance of
these existential threats that would
make us come together as a community
yeah i think that's true if you think of
the war on poverty that president
johnson
pushed that was pretty clear you know it
was unevenly executed but it's pretty
clear and now if we think about
the push for equality in our
society it's kind of hard to be against
philosophically against the fact that
everyone should have an equal
opportunity
yeah but we have not been able to
explain that in a way where
that's what we're forcing people to yeah
to talk about we're talking about other
things
and what we should be talking about is
the idea that every young person
gets a roughly equal start roughly equal
opportunity in life
and that's never going to be perfect but
it
should be our goal you shouldn't be able
to argue against that
i think that's such an interesting point
which is to raise the conversation we're
down in the weeds
yeah and there's a bigger idea here and
black lives matter
has sparked something that is innate in
all of us which is we believe in
fairness every a little child
my little nephew you know something
happens and he'll scream out to me
that's unfair like it's innate
we have a sense of fairness in all of us
and the question is how do we
advance this sense of to your point
everybody gets roughly
the same start what you do with your
start is is up to you i guess
but i don't even know if that's true
that's what black lives matter's
highlighted which is
okay all fine with a good and fair start
but
it's not a fair ride it's not a fair
journey but i do
really appreciate this idea of raising
the conversation but who
it's a great question i mean let's talk
health care for example i think the
conversation should start with
every citizen is going to get health
care adequate health care
for their whole life and people say well
wait a minute are we talking about
single-payer obamacare any number of the
permutations say no we're not talking
about any of that
what we're talking about right now is do
you agree with the idea that everybody
gets health care
if they're bleeding they get bandaged if
they're sick they get taken care of
and all the things you need and people
again would go well yeah
okay of course they'd be careful because
when you get into how you're getting the
arguments
but if we could get a general agreement
that says every american gets health
care
not just because it's fair but because
it's smart for society
it makes us a better society then you
start to work toward it
i think obama made a mistake when he
communicated this
i've gone back and watched he gave a
speech to a joint session of congress
one of the first times he was making a
national argument for national health
care
and he made a rational argument you know
there were 30 million uninsured
americans
it was kind of how the speech started
which to anybody sounds big and
complicated
and sounds expensive as opposed to going
to the foundations of the united states
you know
he could have stood up and said our
founding fathers
founded this nation on three basic
principles all men are created equal
endowed with unalienable rights amongst
which include life liberty in the
pursuit of happiness
let's just talk about one of those let's
just talk about life
the united states is the wealthiest
nation on earth the united states has
the most powerful nation on earth
only our president is referred to as the
leader of the free world then how is it
that america has one of the highest
infant mortality rates amongst western
nations
how is it that we can claim to provide
life for all of
our citizens and yet we cannot even
provide a doctor for every child
there are 30 million uninjured americans
and i think that again
it goes back to a failure of
communication he did not tap
into a sense of shared something or
other that all americans have regardless
of
color creed and politics he went
straight into let me explain something
to you and i think this is where
our leaders and our politicians have
failed us everybody's trying to explain
things to us
i mean you know this from war history
america is losing the psychological
and social fight in vietnam and they're
having press conferences saying
how well they're doing in battle like
the numbers don't matter
yeah you know we lost 58 000 men they
lost 3 million people
how did we lose that's right because we
kept talking about it rationally it
doesn't work
and i think there's a complete breakdown
in this nation of how we are able to
connect
with people how we explain things or
inspire
right and so here's the challenge what
should leaders be doing like
how the heck are we going to inspire
people to want to do something
that comes at personal sacrifice yeah i
think people want to be inspired the one
thing that i think
is true is they desperately want to be
inspired
they're just sort of waiting to be asked
yeah
i think black lives matter is important
on so many levels
there's the obvious one that we need to
reconcile and hold a mirror up to
ourselves as a society and
and sort of admit we need to do a lot
better but i think it's provided an
opportunity for people
to show up you know i think people
forget that the internet is not what
changes society you know
mubarak was not overthrown by twitter he
was overthrown by the
thousands and thousands and thousands of
people who showed up in tahir square
it requires people to physically show up
and it's one of the things i love about
this youngest generation gen z
is they're not online activists they
show up
and they organize and they're having
strikes from school to make a point
and they're building rallies themselves
they're an activist
generation and maybe this activist
generation
is in response it is the pendulum to the
slacktivism that has preceded them
yeah so as i said the black lives matter
movement
it's been a long time since america's
had a movement you know where people
came out on the streets and protested
in massive massive numbers at personal
risk i might add
and i agree with you on that completely
the one thing if i was
advising black lives matter is because
i've written and studied the civil
rights movement
they need to make sure they're not
thinking about this like a battle
it's a war and so they have got to have
enough
persistent pressure on the system
because we both know our country well
enough that
there'll be a certain response and then
as soon as the pressure goes down
there will be stop a progress and in
fact there'll
be some encroachment back and so they
need to understand that
martin luther king jr did it for 13
years till he was murdered
and then other people led the movement
after that
it takes constant inexorable pressure
well it goes back to our impatience as a
society with younger impatient
generations i got to get my career
started and i got to see change now yeah
and
some of that's true yeah but as you said
societal change sticky
societal change right that can survive
the machinations of a political cycle
takes time can you share a specific
story
that you went through something we can
relive with you
where you came out a different version
of yourself
yeah i was a captain for about
seven years so i had about 10 years in
the army
and the first time in the army when you
can be promoted early get an accelerate
promotion
is to major and so this board was coming
up and i was going to be considered
along with thousands of other captains
and i didn't think much about it you
know i didn't really think about getting
but i'd had all the right jobs in fact i
was already in a majors job and people
were telling me how cool i was and
how well i was doing and so part of me
inside
was going ah you know i'm the kind of
guy they pick early
and outwardly i always discount that
well the list
came out and my battalion commander
called me
and he said you're not on the majors
list and i said okay
i can live with that i was hurt but it
wasn't
crushing until i saw the list and
literally
all my friends were on the list or it
seemed like it seemed like
every other captain that i knew really
well
was and i was not and so now not being
on was
really noteworthy and so it crushed me
and i remember my wife annie
you know been married 43 years now but
one of the things she said he goes
okay you didn't make it so what what are
you going to do you going to get out of
the army
and i said no and she says well then you
got to get over it
because if you're not going to get out
and i came away with this
lifelong thing i repeat to other people
i said you know every once in a while
if you get selected for promotion you
say wow
the promotion board is really smart
because they picked me
and i started reminding myself that
later when i got picked for promotions
i said the board that picked me was no
smarter than the board that didn't
and so i need to take any success with
the same
grain of salt i need to be as dismissive
of the process
as i was when i didn't get selected it
was good to happen so early in my career
because
it was a real slap back into humility
that is so great and i'm realizing just
you know when something goes our way we
think how smart though people are and
how good those people are and when it
doesn't go we think what idiots and what
poor leaders they are and how they don't
understand
and it's the same like they're either
idiots all the time and they picked you
for a promotion because they're idiots
or
they're smart they know something that
you don't know i really like the fact
that we treat it equally that's such a
good one
there's a great story that the chief of
staff of the army once told
and he said every year they picked 40
colonels in the army to be brigadier
generals and that's the most difficult
hurdle to get over so it's
2500 get looked at 40 get picks so it's
really the eye of a needle a lot of it's
luck
and he said he was talking to a colonel
one day and he said well what do you
think about this board coming up he said
sir you know every year when the 40
person list comes out there's always one
name that everybody looks at and goes
how did that idiot get on the list what
a joke
and he said sir i want to be that guy
i love it i love it one of the things
that i think most people misunderstand
and misperceive about the military
is you know sure there's a lot of
testosterone and it's a machismo
culture but the intensity of humanity
that exists
there's hand-holding there's hugging
there's crying and crying in the
military is fine
is there someone you think of a fallen
comrade or a story that you grew up with
that you can't get through the story is
there something that has stuck with you
that has become a part of
who you are as stan mcchrystal this
story this person in your life
has now become a part of your the very
way you show up in the world because you
knew them or because of the story you
lived through
there is um christmas eve
it's tradition for commanders to fly
around and visit remote bases
christmas eve christmas day so i was
doing the christmas eve part and then
christmas day would do more
so it was already dark and it was
afghanistan and i'm landing at these
little bases
and i landed at a small little base it
looked like a beaujesque for you know
the afghanistan thing and there's
probably 40 50 americans stationed there
and and
70 radio afghan forces and together
they're
to secure this local area and so we land
outside
and we walk into the uh perimeter and we
go into the mess hall and they've
gathered
most of the people there my sergeant
major and i and two or three others and
we
talk for a few minutes and everybody is
it's always the same they're pretty
tight at first and then you know you you
talk informally
and then the great icebreakers just say
does anybody want to take any pictures
or do anything
and then they all want to take pictures
together and that breaks it down it's
great and so
as i'm given my comments i see a young
private first class and i see the name
and
literally i just froze because
the name was langmack and it was a very
distinct name and there had been a
ranger
sergeant first class that i had served
with in the range regiment when i
commanded the regiment
and then he had gone off to delta force
become an operator and then in 2005
under my command he was killed i knew
steve langmack and his wife quite well
and i'm sitting there and i'm looking at
this guy
at this name tag distracted by my
comments and we went to the
pictures i went over to him and i said
was your father in the service and he
could figure out where i was going with
this right away and he goes yes sir i
said was your father
a ranger he says yes sir and in that
moment
what i realized is we're seeing this
generational service
his father had been killed this kid
didn't have to go in the military he
could have gone and done anything
but not only gone in the military here
he was in this godforsaken part of
afghanistan
on christmas his mom is now home alone
you know she'd been widowed at that
point for four and a half years
and i just realized that he didn't come
and tell me
hey you knew my dad he wasn't gonna do
that
and i just happened to see it and it
reminded me what sort of
quiet service is what sacrifice what his
father had done
what his mother was doing and then what
he was
and so it's one of those things that
whenever i think about that when people
talk about okay you know
i'm doing my part i said okay i'm sure
you are
but i put it against that yardstick a
lot of the stories you tell
are of quiet service you tell the story
of this young man this quiet service
you tell the story of your mother of
quiet service you distinctly pointed out
the quietness of her service
you talk about humility a lot of the
stories you tell are about
quiet and about being humble it's a
theme
in your work it's a theme in the stories
and maybe that's what this is all about
which is maybe the reason we've lost the
sense of sacrifice
is because we're all too busy
advertising ourselves yeah
maybe this has nothing to do with
service maybe the lack of service is a
symptom
that we've lost our humility as
individuals as a nation
you know i see that in the resume
building in young people
where there's more resume than substance
and they've been encouraged to do that
i think we've got a celebrity culture
where we can
confuse celebrity with competence or
leadership
so i think you're probably right what i
think is so funny about america
we celebrate our independence on july
4th 1776.
but we fought the revolutionary war
until the treaty of paris on september
3rd 1783
we actually aren't celebrating our
independence we're celebrating the day
we declared our independence
independence didn't come for another
seven years
before the united states was formally
recognized as independent nation but
that's a very american
thing yeah the declaration is enough
and i think that again there's huge
positives in that you know
europe makes fun of us because we're so
optimistic as a nation
but i think the downside of that is
we're sometimes so busy broadcasting
that we're not spending enough time
listening we're so busy self-promoting
that sometimes we're forgetting the
substance and maybe this is just a point
in time an
inflection point a necessary point for
correction
and sometimes maybe black lives matter
it's that smack across the face that
says
you know maybe you should maybe should
be a little more quiet and a little
more humble like you didn't get
everything right america yeah
you got some things wrong it's okay you
just got to take account you got to make
corrections and you got to
you got to learn your lesson you got to
learn that humility i think there's
something really powerful about quiet
service
and for somebody like you with a storied
career you could tell me any story you
wanted you could have
told me a story of heroism and machismo
and somebody running to battle
and the story you chose to tell me that
you carry with you
as someone you want to be like is this
private first class with quiet service
maybe we all need to just like do that
go serve as opposed to broadcasting what
we
served or intended to do yeah stan i
can't thank you enough
and i'm i'm not going to go into it
people can do their own research on your
career
but knowing how the circumstances under
which you left the army
you are that private first class it was
quiet
and you allowed history to tell the
right story and to get the truth out
later on
i have great respect for just how quiet
you are and just put your head down and
get the job done
it's such a such an honor thanks for all
you do
and thanks for having me today but even
more thanks for all you do you make
people think
sometimes that makes their heads hurt
but you make me think that's one of the
biggest contributions you can make
thank you sir i appreciate it take care
son
[Music]
if you enjoyed this podcast and if you'd
like to hear more please subscribe
wherever you like to listen to podcasts
until then take care of yourself take
care of each other